[Music]
[Applause]
update the poll results there seaton
then we'll get to uh rick stroud who
covers the buccaneers for the tampa bay
times well sadly dan the tides have
turned uh nobody's buying the
mess singer okay yeah yeah part of me
wanted it to be true but then part of me
was like no no
i can't see tom with a goat uh costume
on on the mask singer and then i
wondered the sensitivity level here
and
it kind of came out of nowhere where
todd bowles goes yeah you know we've
known about this but i'm curious how
long ago they knew about this rick
stroud does a great job covering the
buccaneers for the tampa bay times uh
when did the buccaneers know about this
rick
uh they did private training camp that
he was going to take this time off i
mean he told them that he would be in
the first couple weeks would do the
install
you know get with some of the new
players like julio jones and and uh you
know kyle rudolph and those guys and
then he wasn't going to play against
miami he wasn't going to play
uh in 10 against tennessee so you know
he missed 11 days really about
four practices that he would have
participated in so
you know it was something that
they knew about they know the reason for
it as well and uh they were happy to
grant him that time off
um how much do you know on this
uh i know i know enough um but but there
are some things dan and i and i mean
this
that are very personal
and it's i can tell you it you know it
was never health related there's there's
no issues with his children um his wife
i mean it's not
something that or his mom and dad so
it's not of that vain i think when you
say personal reasons it invites
speculation that's just the world we
live in but but even somebody with the
celebrity of tom or giselle
deserve to have you know
time um to do what they need to do and
and with their family so
it is definitely family oriented and and
i i think that we'll
eventually all find out um one way or
the other and you know some some things
we uh we're not privy to print just yet
and and we'll see if tom addressed it i
don't expect him to today um the bucks
are just leaving it up to him you know
however you want to go forward with this
you just tell us but i wondered about
that that i don't know i can understand
the local media maybe protecting brady
in their relationship
but adam schefter and some of the other
insiders
i mean yeah 10 days a long time has
anybody seen tom brady over those 10
days in tampa
uh no and and it's interesting because i
was talking to somebody that's close to
tom in that in that you know sort of
sphere and he said look where could tom
brady go because i thought we'd find him
on a yacht you know in the mediterranean
somebody would some paparazzi was going
to snap a picture somewhere um and he
said look he
his neighbors would have to be birds and
trees because somebody would definitely
um take pictures so wherever it was it
was a it was a you know a private place
and and um they they needed that space
with with the family and like i said i i
think we'll all find out in due time
it's it is interesting you know tom has
as you know you mentioned two of them
very close media partners and
um if they want to continue to be that
you know even even if they're privy to
some information like i said there's
some that's just
too personal to really just just you
know blurt out there and report i
wondered about this when i first heard
when he retired
and then he was coming back and i don't
know if in that moment maybe he made
plans with the family and maybe it was
strategic that hey you're gonna
your body's gonna say let's go play
football again but you're retiring let's
plan something with the family that was
what my thought was
and am i far off on that
um
it's not a vacation let's put it that
way um
was it necessary for him to be with his
family i think so uh did they have it
planned before training camp yeah they
would have but it wasn't as if like hey
you know i was out and we made this
great family plans before school and
we're going to stay committed to that i
do think that you know at 45 having
played 22 years he knows what he has to
do in training camp to get ready there's
still three weeks before the start of
the regular season
if you count the week leading up to the
dallas game so um this was all kind of
built in you know i think um but but
they're like i said i i think we'll find
out a reason here um whether brady
announces it or or it just gets out um
that uh
that is personal and and he'll talk
about it when he's ready to
yeah
interesting sorry i can't be any less
vague yeah no you're doing a good job
i know good not helping you here but but
like if listen if i could print what
what i could print w you would be asking
me about my story and not you know not
just uh to speculate but but there is
there is some there there let's put it
that way well there's they have bigger
issues than what's tom doing now i look
at the offensive line i mean
i thought maybe tom's going damn why did
i come back
like my offensive line isn't good banged
up don't have gronk
how's the team otherwise rick
not good um
i i don't think it's as bad as we think
it is like the guys inside the building
aren't panicking just yet i mean they do
have tom brady so
um i i you know
when when tristan works has you know an
injury but he's day to he's going to
make it back by dallas listen losing
ryan jensen was a big deal and you're
right i watched tom he was he was
crestfallen when you know the guy in
front of them and this is the thing they
changed not just the center but the two
guards those are the guys at tom's feet
that's the closest you know that he's
concerned about he can see guys went off
the edge and he'll be fine throw the
ball away um so there is going to be you
know some some adjustment there but
robert haines he has stepped in they
like what he's done the last two games i
know aaron stinney got hurt you feel bad
for him he was a guard that played
during the super bowl uh in the playoffs
but frankly uh i'm not sure he would
have made this team there's some guys
that are stepping up that are that are
playing better right now but it looked
really bad in tennessee um they got a
rookie playing guard he's got to come a
long way so yeah i mean i watched brady
and it was hot and his center went down
and i'm thinking the same thing like man
you know maybe maybe he should have
stayed retired but um but he he's he's
committed to playing and he got a lot of
these guys to come to tampa because of
that we're talking to rick stroud he
covers the buccaneers for the tampa bay
times yeah i'm looking at cowboys saints
packers chiefs does anybody have a
tougher start to the season than tampa
not a chance not a chance right i think
if you go i mean if you go two and two
in those games you feel probably pretty
good i mean you know depending on who
you beat you're in the nfc south they
haven't beaten the saints yet uh in the
regular season they won the one that
counted on the way to the super bowl um
but yeah that that is a that is a
murderer's row and and you know dallas
is going to be a tough out in the first
game we remember that first game a year
ago it was classic they went on a field
goal at the end um and i don't know how
they navigate that i mean when you're
you're on the road twice and you're
coming home to play the green bay
packers and then and then you've got to
follow that up with kansas city that is
really tough but if they get through
that um not that it gets that much
easier but it does get a little easier
the south is going to come down to them
in new orleans i mean i don't think
carolina's quite ready to make that step
yet with their quarterback situation
certainly atlanta is not um but those
two teams are going to battle it out and
you know when is tom brady lost or not
won at least 11 or 12 games a season and
and i think they're counting on that so
um but yeah that that's as bad i mean
that's as tough as four games and some
national tv games in there that are
night games as well
the raiders story
is that fair game today to bring up to
brady he may not want to talk about his
absence but
can i bring up could somebody bring up
the raiders where
you have dana white saying look i
brokered the deal john gruden nixed it
and
is that the guy that brady is talking
about you're going to stay with that mfr
is it derek carr
it's it's fair question when and if we
get them and then the joke going around
is that john gruden has won two super
bowls for the bucks the one in 2000
on my part you know what i mean
um but but at the end of the day um
you know
are we surprised that tom brady
uh looked into every situation and and
and i mean you know we even san
francisco look they had just won a super
bowl now tom brady
is
emotionally attached to it right grew up
in san mateo
would love to have been part of that
legacy with steve young and joe montana
they took gino karmazi instead or
whatever
but they had just come off the super
bowl they lost but jimmy garoppolo had
gotten a new deal and 49ers had that
discussion and said no so there were
there were teams that said no to tom
brady so my theory was that every team
that said no to him had an mf you know
what i mean like he didn't care who it
was like he was going after all of them
man and he ended up with the confetti so
um but that that is uh
we we've heard about about the raiders
we've heard him looking into miami i
mean nowadays it's tamper bay dan i
don't know if you know that they've
changed the name it's now tamper bay
because everybody wants to try to get
tom brady good to talk to you rick as
always thanks
great seeing you thanks that's rick
stroud covers the buccaneers for the
tampa bay times